hello everyone again and welcome back to
the coverage of the world rabbit
championship after 12 rounds Magnus
Carlsen is in Seoul lead with nine and a
half points and now he faces the last
player to beat him in classical time
control even though this is rapid soccer
my media have defeated him in 2018 bill
chess festival where mama yog had the
white pieces and he defeated the cousins
Kings Indian defense so let's see how
Magnus will approach this now as Magnus
has white so this is again from round 13
let's check it out we have Knight to f3
Magnus goes for the reti opening we have
Knight to f6 sorry about that we have a
c4 e6 Knight to c3 and d5 immediately
striking in the center d4 and now Knight
B to d7 we seek after Sun d5e Capra Sun
d5 and Bishop to g5 now Bishop to e7 and
III so this is all fairly standard stuff
c6 and Queen to c2 now we have castles
by Mahmoud er of Bishop to d3 now
putting pressure on h7 and rook to e8
now no need to do anything like h6 since
if Bishop captures you can capture with
the other night also a h7 will be
guarded and here castling is just the
the move that is being played most often
it is the main line but Magnus goes
Bishop to f4 it's a much rarer move and
it is something Magnus will use to have
to throw me off guard
so Knight back the f8 by Mahmud yarv now
the knight can come to g6 that kick away
the bishop from there for also you just
defended eh so endpoint so now D f6
Knight can move with
h3 making some room for the bishop on f4
if if it's attacked but here mom we all
have challenges at with Bishop to d6
Magnus straits Bishop captures Queen
captures and only now does magnus castle
castling queenside has also been played
here so castles and now this Knight
finally comes to g6 and those are two
very strong Knights controlling a lot of
squares here we look a tabby one with
ideas of starting the expansion on the
Queen side would be 4 and a 4 and Bishop
to d7 now I will be 4 by Magnus
and rook ate the c8 so this is all both
of them are pretty much a blessing now
do these moves this is all well known
rook F the c1 and here Queen back to e7
probably after b5 is played captures
captures the knight will not be
attacking the Queen here so b5 and here
we have a position that was reached in
1994 bits between a vasily when Chuck
and Rafa of a ghanian where c5 was
played and Chuckie won that game but
here we have B captures seek after Sun
b5 and okay Bishop captures this was all
played before Bishop captures night
capture
sorry rook captures on b5 now attacking
the d5 pawn twice although you cannot
capture it since since its pinned the
rook is spinning the night and here
there is one game where rook to c7 was
played but mama DRF plays a different
move mom get off plays Knight to e4 and
it is as a move 19 that we have a
completely new game so a lot of theory
known by these two gentlemen now the
thing is you cannot capture the pawn
here because rook captures and c3 is
coming you cannot capture the point with
the night or the night because you lose
the Queen so those are the things you
know but feel free to pause the video
and try to find the best move for Magnus
as nice that efore was kind of a blunder
by Mahmoud yarv
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who found Queen to be -
congratulations it is the only move that
gives white advantage and for those of
you who just want to enjoy show well yes
it's Queen to be - so here the problem
is now b7 is under attack twice as now
the Queen rogue battery is a threatening
rook a person b7 the d5 pawn is attacked
twice and there is no way to defend all
of it you can go b6 and allow rook
captures on b5 that's one way to do it
but mom Europe decides to go Knight back
to d6 defended the b7 pawn but now
Magnus just grabs the night here and
here Mamiya I've lost a lot of time
trying to figure out his way after that
night Stewie for maneuver Magnus has 12
SEC 12 minutes and 40 seconds on the
clock here whereas mama yah has only 6
minutes and he's still being under
pressure the Queen is under attack
we have rook captures on c1 with
check Queen captures and now getting the
Queen out of harm's way with Queen to
East six and now rook the c5 are
preparing to bring the rook over to the
seventh rank we have rook to d8 now
after the knight moves we will have a
double attack on the night so Magnus
just moves it Knight back to c3 and also
the a two point is now defended since
the Queen from east six was attacking it
we have h6 taking away the g5 square
from the night also giving the King some
breathing room and now Queen the a3
attacking the a7 pawn we have a six by
mama D F and now Queen to a5 so really
really interesting how Magnus improves
the position of the the Queen every move
is a threat Queen to d8 defending the
rook and now Queen to b6 just a
wonderful square for the Queen we have
King to h7 and not looked at d5 with a
double attack on the night so what do
you do here you cannot move the knight
because of rook captures here I'm just
winning the rook so you should play
Queen to e7 it's the only way for mama D
off to continue this struggle although
it's a very passive idea Mahmud Iago
goes for the active idea rook c8 he
wants to trade this night for this night
and Magnus goes for it we have rook
captures and e6 rook captures on c3 and
now Queen captures and b7 Magnus grabs
yet another pawn we have looked the c1
check came to h2 and now rook to c2 mama
DRF will win back at least one of these
pawns or will he well
Magnus played rook to d7 he went after
handy f7 pawn we have King to g8 and
here feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move for Magnus
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that a white
is up two points and that there there
are also a lot of back ranked weaknesses
for black and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
it's rook to c7 this is what Magnus
played and it was in this position that
shot their mommy they are of resigned
the game
incredible stuff and it's incredible how
first against maxime beaugeois graph
almost getting that winning move then
against Levin again achieving the
winning position but then 11 wiggles out
and then gifts Magnus a hole Queen
now Magnus just obliterates Mamedov in
in this miniature it was there was just
nothing to do there
mommy refined found a new mood that was
never played before but it's also a mood
that loses upon and gives black a very
difficult position which is against
Magnus unplayable so here you resign
because if you capture either of the
points then just Queen to rook to c8
wins the Queen there's no way around
this and if you don't if you exchange
looks real characters Queen captures
then you are well
Magnus is just up to pawns and mommy are
have knows that you you will not be able
to play this against Magnus it's not
just up to pawns there's also the past
deep on which is which is starting to
march up the board and this is
unplayable so after rook to c7 mom Yara
resigns and this propels Magnus to ten
and a half out of thirteen points still
with immense lead and it will be very
interesting so he should he has to lose
like the next two games the severely
[ __ ] his performance but since he
didn't lose any games yet he's in a
really great spot to winning the world
rapid championship 2019 so incredible
stuff thirty such a miniature and
remember it's against the person who is
last known to defeat Magnus Carlsen in
2018 in the bill chess festival really
impressive stuff and as the title
suggests this is really the definition
of effortless so once again I would like
to thank Michael Karen Peetz pawn robots
a victor client a David gross skinned
and pray the rock zero for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
world rapid M blitz championship thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Saturday